[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Robert, thank
you for being here.
ROBERT LEE: Of course.
SPEAKER 1: We're
happy to have you.
So as we just
learned in the video,
food insecurity is
very personal to you.
Can you talk more about that?
ROBERT LEE: Sure.
Yeah.
My parents were Korean,
from South Korea,
and they essentially
moved over without really
knowing any English.
And so my dad was
a civil engineer
and my mom was a banker.
But when they came
over to the States,
that really didn't
matter because they
didn't know any English.
And so I remember the
times when we just
are one huge bowl of ramen
for a meal for the whole day
because that was pretty much it.
And you know, as I
mentioned in the video,
you just think that's normal and
you just kind of live with it.
But it was to the point
where I just hated ramen
because we just had it so much.
But I grew up with kind of
that kind of environment.
And my parents would
always tell me about how
any food that you--
I'm sure people have the same
experience in terms of stories
that they're told.
But I was told that any
food that I would waste
would basically have to be eaten
in my afterlife all at once.
So I kind of grew
up with the values
of never wasting food and
really cherishing food
whenever we had it.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
Very cool.
And you won a CNN Hero Award
and you're on Forbes 30
Under 30 Social
Entrepreneurs list.
Your parents must be very proud.
So what prompted you-- you left
a very secure job in finance
and you started RLC.
What prompted that?
ROBERT LEE: Oh, man.
So many things.
I think because the two
issues were so close to me
and so personal, I think having
the opportunity to kind of give
back in this way, in such a
direct and commonsense way
and efficient way,
and the opportunity
to scale a solution that was
such a huge problem, food
waste and hunger and all
these different kind of facets
of those two things.
And while I was
working at JP Morgan,
I kind of compared my
time of how much time
I was spending and what
impact that had at JP Morgan,
and the same amount
of time and impact
it would have had
Rescuing Leftover Cuisine.
It was just two worlds apart.
And I just couldn't
take it anymore
and wanted to do something
more meaningful with my time,
and had an outlet to do it.
So I took the opportunity,
took the risk.
And yeah, it was great.
SPEAKER 1: A risk
analyst who took a risk.
I love it.
It's great.
Thank you.
OK, so what was the
process of starting RLC?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
So starting RLC pretty much
came from way back into college.
So during college was when
I came across the concept
of food rescue.
There was a club that
brought leftover dining hall
food to homeless shelters
called Two Birds One Stone.
SPEAKER 1: At NYU, right?
ROBERT LEE: At NYU.
And it basically kind
of opened my eyes
to food rescue as a
concept, and to the fact
that food can be
donated, and that there's
so much excess food.
So we were basically--
a bunch of us, a couple
of friends and I,
were kind of executive
board members
of that club and kind of
expanded it throughout the four
years of NYU, because it
started out as just one
dining hall to one
homeless shelter.
But eventually,
under our leadership,
were able to grow it out to
all the different dining halls,
and basically grow it out.
And that kind of opened
my eyes to the fact
that it's not just dining halls.
It's also restaurants and
different food businesses
that can donate their food, and
that there's such a huge need
at homeless shelters.
And so that first
experience paved the way
for the first inkling of an idea
of RLC at Two Birds One Stone.
We kind of did everything
on a Google spreadsheet,
coordinating all these
different volunteers and things
like that.
But we had this dream of
having an automated system that
would connect excess food
to homeless shelters,
and have volunteers be the
solution because during college
years, we had the time
to do a bunch of research
and figure out that
solutions to food rescue,
in terms of food rescue, existed
and had really great impact
in terms of great work of
City Harvest and Food Bank
and things like that.
But there was a little bit of
a gap of how much food there
was out there versus
what they could pick up.
And so we wanted to basically
tackle that specific gap
and operate in that
niche with the model
that we kind of learned and
perfected during the college
years.
And so we took all
that kind of together
and then entered into
a venture competition,
ended up winning
some seed money,
and pretty much launched it
from there and kept on going.
SPEAKER 1: Very cool.
So what's the biggest
challenge that you've
faced as a social entrepreneur?
ROBERT LEE: There's so many.
I think-- in general, I
think the uncertainty is
the biggest challenging aspect.
There's no way to
project in terms
of how many new food donors
we're going to bring on board,
how much pounds of
food we're going
to be able to bring on board.
But you kind of rely on
the different aspects
that you can rely on, like
how much time you put in,
how much effort you put
in, how many volunteers you
can corral to the cause.
And you basically
see what happens.
Because of how local it
is and how small it is,
it's sometimes outsized in terms
of expectations of what you
would think you get out of it.
But it turns out to be
really good sometimes.
So I would say just
that uncertainty
is the biggest challenge.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
So let's talk about
food waste, which
is astounding in this country.
We heard a few
stats in the video,
but since you're the
expert, I would love
for you to talk more about it.
Give us all of your
wisdom on food waste.
ROBERT LEE: Sure.
I think-- yeah.
When you think about food
waste, it is just food waste.
But when you think about
the different facets of what
that means, it's kind of mind
blowing because it's not just
about food waste.
It's about the
environmental impact
of that food waste, the
moral implications, what
that food has potential
to do, as well
as the actual economic
impact of that.
So on the environmental
issue, people don't really
know that food waste
is one of the largest,
if not the largest component of
solid waste in the waste stream
and actually lands in landfills,
where it basically contributes
to carbon emissions through
methane gases, which
is actually 20 times
worse than carbon dioxide.
And if you take food waste
as a kind of a global emitter
of carbon emissions and take it
out as if it's like a country,
it would rank third right
after the USA and China.
So just as a kind of
environmental issue
after the fact of wasting food,
it's a huge kind of issue.
But even going
before that supply
chain of actually wasting
the food, the amount of land,
amount of natural resources
used to grow that food is all
wasted as well.
To grow the food that we
all eat in this country,
we use half the US land,
80% of the US fresh water.
10% of US energy budget
is used to transport
that food in trucks and supply
chain and things like that.
So all of that is wasted when
you waste 40% of the food
that you're producing.
So it's the environmental
impact on both sides.
And so when you
combine those things,
it's a huge, huge,
non-negligible amount.
And that's just the
environmental side.
I mean, there's a whole bunch
of studies and things like that.
And I think there
needs to be more
studies on the environmental
impact of food waste.
But the NRDC does a really
good job of telling people
about the issue of food waste.
And one of the other things
that they mention, obviously,
is the fact that the potential
of food waste is huge.
It's a $165 billion
dollar problem in the US.
It's obviously an
economic issue.
People are buying food
from the supermarkets
and then wasting it.
You might as well just
not buy 40% of the food
that you're buying
at the supermarket.
So it's a huge
economic cost as well.
Obviously, the US
energy budget and things
like that, that's
our taxes going
into food that's like going to
be wasted, like corn, subsidies
for corn.
Why do we do that?
Yeah, it's a huge, complex
issue, and implications
that people don't really
think about when you think
about it on a deeper level.
Obviously, along the lines
of potential food waste,
the food that's actually
going to waste obviously
can feed people.
So people can be fed with that.
And what's more important
than feeding people that
are hungry and need that food if
you're going to be wasting it?
And when you think
about the flip side
to that equation of
food waste and hunger,
49 million Americans
are food insecure.
And I mention in
the video, if you
think about the nutritional--
and obviously poverty is
a multi-faceted issue as well,
and it's not just nutrition--
but if you think about
just nutrition, reducing
30% of the wasted
food and bringing
that directly to the
people who are food
insecure would eliminate hunger,
which means that there's still
2/3 of food waste leftover that
needs to be reduced as well,
which is why there's the food
waste hierarchy of reducing it
on source and then
feeding people, feeding
animals, composting, and
then lastly, landfill.
But I'm kind of going on
and on about food waste.
You know, it's just so much.
It's so much.
And it's a huge, huge issue.
SPEAKER 1: So how do we
compare to other countries?
ROBERT LEE: The US
throws out a lot.
The average that people say
is 40%, according to reports.
On the worldwide level,
we waste about 30% of food
that we produce in the world.
It's a lot.
And US is obviously
a little bit worse.
But it's interesting
because the US,
obviously, as one of
the developed nations,
seems to waste a lot
more food on our end,
on the consumer end, which means
there's a lot of education that
needs to happen in terms of
recognizing that food waste is
a problem, but also
doing something about it,
and doing easy things that
can be simply implemented
in all of our lives.
In terms of developing nations,
a lot of their food waste
is happening on the
agricultural-- on the earlier
side of the supply chain because
they don't have the technology
or they don't have the
resources to implement
the kind of systems that
they have in the US.
So it's a shame, because
obviously the story that I just
mentioned about having
enough nutrition in the US
is the same.
It's parallel across
the world as well.
In the world, if we reduce
just one third of the food
that we have going
to waste, that
could be easily enough to
eliminate food insecurity
in the world.
So we talk about overpopulation
and the fear of feeding
everyone and things like that.
But no one is thinking about
why not reduce the food
waste that we have going
on to solve that problem?
I mean, we don't have
to increase production.
We can just be more
efficient with the food
that we're already producing.
I think overall, people
are becoming more and more
aware of the issue.
And I'm glad that people are
starting to pay attention.
SPEAKER 1: So is food
waste getting better
or is it getting worse?
Is it sort of the same?
ROBERT LEE: I think
there's not as much data
as there needs to be in terms
of measurement and things
like that.
I think even more
granular reports
need to be published
in terms of where
specifically in the supply
chain food is being wasted.
But in general, it seems like
the problem of food waste
is becoming more and more
of a mainstream issue
that people are
caring about, just
in terms of the sheer number
of articles and attention
that people are
putting on food waste
has been increasing in the
past three or four years.
We're lucky in that we
just started in 2013,
and it's been a huge increase
in the level of attention
that people are putting
into food waste.
So we do believe that
it's getting better.
But there's still obviously
a lot of work to be done.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So you've started RLC.
So how is RLC
solving the problem?
How is it different than
other organizations?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
That's pretty much the number
one question we always get.
But we started it in 2013
because, as I mentioned
a little bit earlier,
we started to notice
that there was kind of a gap or
niche in the food rescue space.
And when we started thinking
about outside the border of NYU
and how food rescue
can be applied,
we did a lot of research into
City Harvest and Food Bank
and even OzHarvest in
Australia and things
like that to figure out what
solutions already existed
and what was happening
and what was working.
And so we realized that,
at least for New York City,
the current solutions
typically had a minimum pound
requirement, where
they would not
go by for food that was under
a certain number of pounds.
So we decided to
essentially target
that specific gap, that
niche market, and essentially
kind of use our solution
to that problem.
So we like to think of
ourselves as different in terms
of that minimum
pound requirement
because we don't
have one, but also
in the fact that we use a kind
of technology-driven process
by using a web
application code on Ruby
on Rails that basically allows
people to kind of sign up
online for any
pickup that they want
and crowdsource that
transportation problem,
that distribution problem
between the excess food
and the hungry.
So yeah, there's a whole
bunch of other kind of things.
I think one of the other
ways we're different
is that we are
much more scalable
and that we have this kind
of platform that can just
be kind of basically put to use
in different geographic areas,
not just New York City.
And in other
models, you may have
to actually own
trucks, and own trucks
and operate trucks in
each different city
that you're running in.
So we don't have
that kind of issue.
SPEAKER 1: So with RLC,
there's three parties.
You have a food partner or a
donor, you have the volunteers,
and then you have the shelter.
So if I'm a food partner,
what does that look like?
ROBERT LEE: For a
food donor, we try
to make it as easy as
possible because it's
sometimes difficult
for food donors
to feel comfortable
about donating food.
There's always so many stigmas
and myths around donating food.
So we try to make it
as easy as possible,
and we cater to the
food donors' needs.
So as a food donor, when
they partner with RLC,
they're first asked when
they throw out their food
and at what frequency.
So for example, just thinking
about any coffee shop,
they may have pastries and
muffins at the end of the night
that they throw out when
they're closing out for the day.
And so they can tell
us, hey, we actually
have these muffins and
pastries that we throw out
every single night at
9:00 PM when we close.
And what we can do is
essentially basically
ensure that we're there at
that time every single day
and make it super easy for them.
Instead of throwing it
out into a trash bag,
just put it into a
different container
that they can actually donate.
We do the transportation, we
do all the paperwork and things
like that for them
and make it super easy
for them to feel the
impact and understand
that their food is going to
the hungry without actually
doing that much work.
SPEAKER 1: You mentioned there's
myths about donating food.
So you often hear that it's
illegal to donate food,
you can't do it, which is
why restaurants throw it out.
But that's not necessarily
true, especially with RLC.
Can you talk more about that?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
The number one pushback
we get from restaurants
and other food businesses
is that it's illegal,
which is unfortunately just
widespread for some reason.
There's a Bill Emerson
Good Samaritan Act of 1996
that's a federal law that
basically protects all food
donors from legal liability,
except in the case
of gross negligence, which is
basically extreme carelessness.
So as long as they're adhering
to all the food safety
standards and ensuring that
they are a licensed food vendor
and they know how to
handle food and donating
food in the right way,
there's no legal liability.
Of course, if they throw
the food on the ground
and then donate, that's
obviously not the same thing.
But the federal law
existed since 1996,
but all 50 states have
also passed state versions
of that same exact
Good Samaritan Law,
in some cases actually
helping to provide even more
additional protections
for food donors.
So it's kind of insane to hear
sometimes from restaurants
that they heard
that McDonald's got
sued for some reason or
another about food insecurity
and people being sick off of
that food that they donated.
And there's no legal case.
There's nothing in the
case record about that.
So it's just myths.
And people have been doing
food rescue for over 35,
40 years now.
And as long as we are all
adhering to the same food
safety standards ensuring
that the food is safe,
food can be donated and
can be completely fine.
So yeah, I think that's
the number one education
point that needs to happen
for people to really start
understanding that licensed
food vendors, people that
can actually prepare the
food correctly and safely,
can donate that food.
SPEAKER 1: Good to know.
So it's so great
you have restaurants
that donate the food.
Do you report back any data,
you know, letting them know,
this is how much you're wasting?
Can you talk about that?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
So one of the benefits that
we provide for restaurants
is the data piece
because there's
a hierarchy of what
food waste should go to.
I mentioned it a little bit.
The number one thing is to
reduce it from the get-go.
And for that, it pretty much
is thinking about creative ways
to use excess food
and things like that,
or just from the very production
of it, just don't produce it.
And so we provide monthly data
in terms of days and number
of pounds on how much
food is being donated
and thus would have been wasted
if they didn't work with us.
And what that
allows the partners
to do is essentially analyze
that data and see, oh, hey,
I did not expect that much
food to be going to waste.
There's a lot of partners that
we've worked with initially
that have given us
estimates like, oh, yeah,
it's going to be
about 40 pounds.
And it turns out
to be 40 pounds.
For the first two, three
weeks, it turns out
to be over 100 pounds.
And that's because they're
just not measuring it.
And just like any KPI, if
you're not measuring it,
you can't do anything
about it, right?
And so basically having
that monthly data allows
them to do not just looking at
and measuring out food waste
data, but also thinking
about, oh, hey,
every Monday or
every weekend we seem
to have much more food
waste than other days.
And they can use that,
internalize that, and basically
reduce it on their own.
Typically food donors
want to, obviously, keep
every single sale
that they have.
So there's always going to
be a little bit of food that
is going to go to waste.
But we typically see the
numbers kind of start
to come down and
plateau over time.
And that's one of the kind of
key things that we like to do,
is ensure that we're measuring
our food waste in terms
of our success metrics,
but also keeping
in mind that we don't
want to necessarily
have more pounds of food.
We retain our main KPI
and main success measure
as the number of
partners because that's
the real measure of success in
terms of what we're thinking.
SPEAKER 1: So before
we get to volunteers,
let's talk about the shelters
or the food recipients.
What does it look like for them?
ROBERT LEE: So for
the food recipients,
they're typically
homeless shelters,
soup kitchens, food
pantries, community centers,
things like that.
They're 501(c)3
non-profit organizations.
And typically what happens
is, after we find a restaurant
partner that has a certain
number of pounds of food,
and they give us an expectation
of what type of food
is going to go to waste
and things like that
and can be donated, we
go and match that up.
We have great, wonderful
staff to help us do this.
And they basically
help match the food
to what food is needed at
the homeless shelters, soup
kitchens, and food pantries.
And that way it can be a
regular, recurring food
item that can basically
offset the food that they
would normally buy.
So they can expect it.
They know how much, typically,
on average, it's going to be,
and essentially they can take
that out of the food budget.
And so that kind of
partnership really
starts with the food donor.
And on the food recipient
side, they receive it,
they give us a receipt
that basically helps us
measure the number of pounds.
And that basically goes
back to the food donor
and helps us
maintain our records.
SPEAKER 1: And so
for the shelters,
their goal is probably that
they never have to buy food.
That's the goal for them,
because they still do.
ROBERT LEE: Yeah, they still do.
SPEAKER 1: Have to buy food.
ROBERT LEE: They still do.
SPEAKER 1: Oy.
ROBERT LEE: Yeah, it's insane.
There's just so
much food out there.
But it's always about
the right type of food,
because different
homeless shelters
have different
requirements because they
do different services.
Like some of them do just
breakfast or some of them
do just dinner.
And so bringing a bunch
of bagels to someone
that just does dinner
is not helpful.
So it's just making
that matching.
And that's kind of where we
can make that matching happen.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
OK.
So let's talk about volunteers
because without volunteers,
the organization
doesn't really run.
I mean, there are other reasons.
So what does it look like if you
are a volunteer, if you sign up
to volunteer?
ROBERT LEE: So anyone
can go online and sign up
to volunteer at Rescuing
Leftover Cuisine.
It's just www.rescuingleft
overcuisine.org/calendar.
And there's basically a
list of all the events
that we have in your region.
And essentially the
events or rescues
are listed in
chronological order
and in different locations
within your region.
So for example, in New
York City, there's FiDi,
there's Midtown, there's Upper
West Side, Upper East Side.
And essentially
people can filter down
and look on a map view
as well and figure out
what time and location
they're available to help out.
These pickups are
volunteer opportunities
that are really easy to kind
of fit into your schedule
because it's just 30 minutes
of your time to an hour.
So you can do it easily
on your way to work,
on your way between
classes or between the gym
and other things, or
in place of the gym.
And you essentially can
help make direct impact
because you're going
to actually see--
after you sign up you'll get
an automated confirmation
e-mails and all this, and you'll
get the contact information
of the person who's going
to be leading your event.
And once you meet
with everyone, you
can actually see the actual food
that's about to go to waste.
The restaurant's
cleaning up, you
get to see the aluminum tins
or bags and things like that.
And you can actually rescue
that and walk it over.
Sometimes it will be
15 minutes walking,
sometimes it will be
five minutes of walking.
Sometimes it will be
a little bit more,
25 minutes of walking.
But it will be within
that neighborhood,
same neighborhood.
And that's kind of what
I love about the model is
it's just local.
It's just local restaurants
helping local homeless shelters
with local volunteers.
And that's it.
They drop it off,
they get the receipt,
and they upload it online
through the application.
And that's it.
They made that impact.
They can see the people,
the line of people
outside the homeless
shelter that's
going to be fed with that food.
So it's immediate.
It's that impact
that they get to see.
So for a volunteer, it's
typically super easy.
If people want to get
even more involved,
they can be a lead rescuer,
much like yourself.
And people can lead
on a weekly basis
and actually help
lead other volunteers
and take them through
the route and be kind
of responsible for that route.
So yeah, there's a lot
of ways to help out
in your neighborhood.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
I am a volunteer.
I volunteer every week
with the organization.
It's exactly what you said.
It's just very, very simple.
I found you on VolunteerMatch,
which is where every volunteer
opportunity is listed.
And I just couldn't
believe it was that simple.
And I think for people with
busy schedules, like all of us,
it really is perfect.
And it's also a great way to get
exercise, to bring your friends
and do it.
Everyone's trying to save money,
not go to the bar at night.
Bring them to a shift.
Yeah, and it truly is 30
minutes to an hour door to door.
But yeah, to bring the food in
and to walk it into a shelter,
and to see the people who are
going to eat it right there,
is just so wonderful.
That's what I love about RLC.
With other
organizations, I think
there's a long orientation
process, and a wait list.
And this is just click,
sign up, show up,
and just kind of do it.
Very, very simple.
Couldn't believe
it was that simple.
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
We try to make it
easy because we really
need as many people to
help with this problem
because food waste is happening
literally everywhere around us.
And we're all just
moving all the time.
And if we were moving
with excess food
and dropping it off while
we were going to places,
it would just make
it so much easier,
and we could solve this problem.
So we didn't want
that to be a barrier.
And we wanted to give
the power to the people
to basically make a
difference in this problem.
But of course, there's
the lead rescuers
to make sure that
people are not stealing
the food and things like that.
But the lead rescuers
are kind of--
all the volunteers are kind
of the crux of this model.
SPEAKER 1: And so
you've expanded.
So you started in New York
City and you've expanded
to how many cities now?
ROBERT LEE: 16.
SPEAKER 1: 16 cities
around the US.
How is that expansion,
and what are the--
ROBERT LEE: It's exciting.
I mean, it's a lot of work.
It's exciting to see that
it's not just New York City
because New York City
is such a unique city.
We started here.
We're headquartered here.
But it's very different
in other branches.
New York City, you
can walk because there
are homeless shelters and
kitchens literally 15 minutes,
20 minutes away on
foot from places.
And you'll never know it.
But in places like other
cities, any other city,
you'll have to drive.
And we had to figure out
what's the right model
to tweak the
technology a little bit
to accommodate for that
and things like that.
But it's working
out really well.
It's also very different terms
of the types of food businesses
that are outside
of New York City.
A lot of the pounds of food that
we get are sometimes larger.
But it's exciting.
We currently are working
on a lot of the lower
end of the supply chain
in terms of restaurants,
retail businesses.
But eventually, obviously
the food waste problem
is so complex that we
wanted to help out--
with the same technology
and the same system--
help out with any level
of the supply chain
wherever excess
food is happening.
So it's exciting, but obviously
a lot of things to consider.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
If anyone has any
questions, you can line up
at the mics in the aisles, and
I'll keep asking you questions.
So what can people do?
Of course they can volunteer.
What other types of things
do you need help with?
I believe you got
a grant last year.
What does your
organization need?
ROBERT LEE: So yeah,
last year we actually
got a grant from Google,
which was really amazing.
Thanks again for that.
SPEAKER 1: It wasn't me.
ROBERT LEE: But it helped
us develop our technology.
And at the crux of it, this
is a technology-driven system.
Without the technology
we would have
to have five more
staff members that
are coordinating and sending
emails and sending reminder
emails and things like that.
But with this technology
we were able to scale it
up and be much more efficient.
So in terms of ways that people
can help, there's so many.
On the most basic level,
you can give time,
you can give resources,
you can give contacts.
So on the time
side, obviously, you
can sign up as a
regular volunteer
and sign up whenever you want,
whenever you're available.
And if you want to
invest even more time,
you can be a lead rescuer,
you can be a core rescuer
doing 10 times a week.
And you can help us out in the
office with your skill sets
and things like that.
And then on the resources
side, obviously we're a 501(c)3
nonprofit organization.
And so we basically depend
on monetary donations
to continue to grow and expand.
We do have operations that
allow us to organically grow
in terms of having the
operations covered by
earned revenue.
So any donations
that people make
are contributing directly to
the growth, which is really
why we have been able
to expand so quickly
over the past few years.
So for example, last
year we doubled.
The year before
that we quintupled.
So we were able to
do this because we
have the kind of model
that we can continue
to be able to be sustainable.
And then on the contact
side, we are an organization
that works with a lot of
different parties, restaurants,
catering companies, farms,
wholesalers, retailers.
There are so many
different food businesses,
food-related organizations.
There's food waste everywhere,
places that people don't even
think about like stadiums,
fashion shoots, photo shoots.
It's just literally everywhere.
It's not just the restaurants
and things like that.
So contacts that people
have to these people that we
can basically set
up a relationship
and make it really easy to
donate their food is ideal.
And obviously, on the
homeless shelter side,
if people have
contacts to places
where we can partner with
to distribute the food,
that's a huge help as well.
So lots of ways.
But I would say number
one, just volunteer time.
Go onto our website,
sign up online.
SPEAKER 1: It's so fun.
You meet really cool people.
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
Great way to meet people.
SPEAKER 1: It really is, yeah.
We have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I think the work
you guys do is amazing,
and also it's in an area I
don't know that much about.
So I learned a lot today.
Thank you.
I kind of had a question
around food insecurity
is not a problem like
medicine or something,
where a person needs
a one-time treatment
and then you've fixed them.
You need food every single day.
And so it is a
structural problem.
And I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about some
of the stuff you
mentioned earlier about
do cities have programs where
they do some food waste pickups
and stuff for shelters already?
Or is that an area where
there is room for you
to expand from the
volunteer and nonprofit side
to policy advocacy at all?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
That's a really great question.
There's a bunch of different
levels to that question.
But in terms of
what RLC is doing
to help with the food insecurity
issue, as I mentioned,
food insecurity, and
poverty in general,
is a really complex issue.
And nutrition is just
one piece of the problem.
And food waste is going
to help contribute
to the overall solution
to that problem.
And the way we see it
is the amount of money
that we can save the homeless
shelters from buying food,
they can use that money to have
much more long-term solutions
like job skills
training, shelter,
and basic needs and
things like that.
And we see ourselves as part of
the solution to that problem.
So in terms of policy
and things like that,
we're really excited
about making sure
that food rescue becomes
more and more mainstream,
and hopefully even
required in the future,
maybe, similar to what France
is doing and things like that.
But it seems like that's
a bit further away,
especially with current events.
But it seems like
policy is something
that's really important to
make this a requirement,
to make this at least much more
mainstream across food business
as a whole.
So hopefully that
answers both questions.
SPEAKER 1: Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thank you for coming out today.
ROBERT LEE: Of course.
AUDIENCE: Obviously you're
founded here in New York
and based here.
You're talking about expanding
to other cities and whatnot.
If somebody wanted to start
this same kind of program
in any other city, and still
go under your same brand
and be part of your
organization and your resources,
how would we do that?
Do you have franchising
opportunities or things?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
Basically I guess it's
kind of like franchising,
but it's for a nonprofit.
But it's the same
type of process.
We have a branch application
process that you go through.
Happy to give out
that information.
The number one way is
to go onto our website
and contact us about
the opportunity,
or email us at info@rescuinglef
tovercuisine.org.
And essentially
it's just kind of
to create a branch
in any area, you just
need to have a certain
number of people
that are dedicated to the
cause to grow the branch
and things like that.
But yes, we require
help from people
that are local to understand
the local environment,
and do the research of what
exists and what's working,
what's not working
in that specific area
because the worst
thing that we can do
is duplicate effort
that's already happening.
And we did a ton of
research in the beginning
to make sure that we
weren't duplicating efforts,
we were targeting
that niche market.
And so we would basically
figure out that together.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: I'm curious.
You mentioned that what
sets you apart from others
is that you have this
technology component.
Is there a bigger goal
for the technology of--
what?
What does that look like?
ROBERT LEE: Yeah.
There's so much we can do.
Currently it's a
web application.
And it's code on Ruby
on Rails, and we're
trying to push towards a
progressive web application,
which I think, actually,
is a Google thing.
But what we would love to do
is make this a more mobile app
type of situation that uses
location settings, that
uses push notifications
and things like that.
Right now we're relying on
texts and emails and things
like that.
But push notifications
and location settings
would be huge
because as we scale,
as we have more and
more restaurants
and pickups, that
kind of randomly,
logistically in terms of
sheer number of volunteers
and sheer number of
pickups that are happening,
there are going to be more
opportunities of people calling
out or not going to be
able to make the event
and things like that.
And if we had the
mobile capability
to basically say, hey,
you're in the area,
and have a push notification
that goes and asks those people
to basically cover
that event, that
would be a huge game changer.
And there's so many
other things we
want to do with the
technology out there.
There is also the
whole transportation
industry right now is
going through the automated
transportation system going on.
And one of the things
that we want to,
and we're excited
about trying to pilot,
is figuring out how that kind
of automated driver situation,
or drone situation, can
be applied to food rescue
because it totally
can, and it could
be a great solution to applying
technology to age-old issues.
So yeah, there's so
many exciting things.
Yeah.
There is great potential there.
SPEAKER 1: So in a perfect
world, no food is wasted.
What happens to RLC?
ROBERT LEE: Well,
see, that's the thing.
I think because--
I've always struggled with that.
I think it's also because of my
background working at JP Morgan
and for profit.
I think when I went to
the nonprofit space,
it was difficult to
have the right KPI.
And I mentioned that number of
partners was most important.
And one of the reasons
why we consciously
decided to go with a
volunteer-driven model
was so that we can scale
up and down as needed.
If the restaurant
starts at 120 pounds,
we can have 10 volunteers
carrying 12 pounds each.
But then if it goes
down to 40 pounds
and they're able to
reduce it on site,
then we can just
bring four volunteers.
And so the way we see
it is we basically
can use whatever we have at our
disposal in terms of volunteers
to accommodate whatever
capacity is required.
But we're not reliant on it.
We're not looking to have
a lot of pounds of food
so that we can pare employees.
We want to be able to
remain nimble and actually
solve the problem rather
than perpetuating it.
Very
SPEAKER 1: Cool Any
other questions?
All right.
Well, if you have one call
to action or one thing
you'd like to leave
with, and also
if you could remind
everyone of the website.
ROBERT LEE: Yes, of course.
So yeah, the number one thing
is going onto our website
at rescuingleftover
cuisine.org/calendar
and signing up for
your first pickup.
It's a really great way to check
us out, go on to a delivery
and figure out what we do.
SPEAKER 1: All day every day.
ROBERT LEE: All day every day.
Seven days a week.
The video said, I think,
10:00 to midnight.
Now we do pretty much
like 8:00 AM to 2:00 AM.
So no excuse.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
It's 30 minutes.
Yeah.
ROBERT LEE: But yeah,
it's really great.
It's a really great
way to help out.
SPEAKER 1: Robert,
thank you for coming.
ROBERT LEE: Thank you
so much for having me.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.